Lots of "Law & Order" episode ideas are ripped
from the headlines, but one proved so painful
that NBC will never air it again.
Which one was it?
Watch and see.
When "Law & Order" made its debut on NBC in
1990, the procedural crime drama offered a
novel concept for the small screen.
One part of the show presents detectives working
to solve a criminal case, while the other
half depicts prosecutors working in the courtroom
to process that same case.
It's a formula that successfully launched
many spin-offs and one that fans will enjoy
yet again when "Law & Order" finally runs
its 21st season after over a decade off the
air.
But "Law & Order" also has another significant
story element its writers use to help anchor
its aim for gritty realism.
Something that went a long way in making this
realistic approach possible was the tendency
for "Law & Order" to use actual criminal cases
from the news as the basis for some of its
episodes.
Even some of its offshoots, like "Law & Order:
SVU," have produced numerous tales inspired
by true crimes throughout their runs, turning
real-life tragedy into harrowing fiction.
However, when pulling from news headlines
for story inspiration, it's incredibly important
to do so in a manner that's just as tasteful
as it is entertaining.
After all, the real people the episodes are
based on have real trauma.
“[I am not going to apologize for doing
what needs to be done to put this monster
behind bars.”
https://youtu.be/mfMcpkSLeoU?t=339 to 5:45]
As one could imagine, attempts at this approach
are prone to go awry from time to time.
For example, a 2001 episode of "Law & Order"
caused so much controversy that NBC never
aired it again.
The "Law & Order" installment that caused
quite a stir with viewers was Season 11's
11th episode, "Sunday in the Park with Jorge
[HOR-hay]."
The plot dealt primarily with a millionaire's
wife being discovered dead in Central Park
following the annual Puerto Rican [POHR-tuh
REE-kin] Day Parade.
Meanwhile, a riot broke out during the event
where several other women were horrifically
sexually assaulted.
Much like many episodes of "Law & Order,"
"Sunday in the Park with Jorge" was loosely
based on a real and terrible event, but what
set it apart from all of the others and prompted
NBC to scrub it from television?
When the episode premiered, not much time
had passed since the Puerto Rican Day Parade
attacks, with them occurring only a year prior.
During the event, several women came forward
with their assault stories — moments that
surely none of them would've liked to revisit
in the form of a TV drama.
According to the Chicago Tribune, NBC held
a meeting with activist groups like the National
Puerto Rican Coalition, who felt that the
episode gave an offensive depiction of members
of the Latino community.
The network heard out their complaints, and
as a result, the network decided never to
air the episode again.
Now 20 years beyond its debut, the banishment
of "Sunday in the Park with Jorge" from the
airwaves still stands.
While this may seem like an overall good decision
that wouldn’t really invite much pushback,
not everyone agreed with NBC's choice.
Arguably the loudest voice in that crowd was
the mastermind behind "Law & Order" himself,
Dick Wolf.
He made no bones about his disagreement with
the network in the days following the announcement
of its verdict.
The Chicago Tribune quoted him as saying,
"The network has caved in to the demands of
a special interest group, and I am extremely
disappointed with this decision."
He added that NBC's lack of communication
with him during the deliberation process was
particularly irritating.
He also posited that the move sets an extremely
dangerous precedent.
The Washington Post quoted a statement from
Wolf asserting that the show “reflects real
life,” and virtually any member of any group
can fit the antagonist role given certain
narrative circumstances.
The "Law & Order" franchise has aired many
episodes that fans might find too hard to
watch, and for many, that's a part of the
appeal.
It's a dramatized yet realistic look at our
world created for entertainment.
Nevertheless, some have argued that it has
occasionally gone too far for a network TV
show, which is exactly why NBC sought to avoid
the trouble and never rerun the episode again.
If you or anyone you know has been a victim
of sexual assault, help is available.
Visit the Rape, Abuse & Incest National Network
website or contact RAINN's National Helpline
at 1-800-656-HOPE (4673).